I'm tired I'll be in here you stayed it
is sexy Monday here on its grace and I
am so sleepy I just got back from Vegas
Las Vegas in Nevada mamrie Hart and
myself and our friend Jocelyn Hughes
went and saw
whoosh it was great you'll see all about
it in Friday hurry I am so tired that I
decided I understand do
stream-of-consciousness sexy Monday
sorry if you hate this with your life
there are a lot of other things to eat
in this world
disappointing cheesecake pleated pants
calyx how's that lick you cows at lucky
moose we're back
did I focus this I did am I focused of
course not that's what makes it fun it's
why Jake someone whose identity whose
brain is slowly turning in to actual
dirt in her brain but when there is dirt
you can build a rain forest what
happened in Vegas I'll give you some key
words Britney Spears Lemon Drop martini
this is not a real gun this is a lighter
but when you pull this part it shocks
you so of course you're gonna buy this
and now this is a tax deduction being a
creative is really kind of cool
and your brain is turning into a well
where are they today you can build
condos can't Dakota comes out this
Friday and I'm so excited
captain calm calm co-op Rio to the film
I am NOT doing Valentine's Day I am
literally dating my social media all day
to anticipate all of your thoughts and
feelings about the movie I think that
felt great
I won $100 playing electronic blackjack
what's happening in so in life and
things I feel out of the loop here's the
loop and here's me I'm trying to do this
get into the loop Oh Shia LeBouf wore a
bag on his head that says I am NOT
famous anymore exact good penmanship
Brianna and Drake might be dating again
what's their ship name rake we rake
Briana why doesn't Benny find de Triana
their ship name would be Ben IANA all
right enough with politics I think I'm
getting session isn't that just a fun
terrible thing to say to people you just
asking people to be like oh no oh
steak
goes camp Takota calm whatever is
happened in my chest you know sometimes
you just like today today that I get a
heart attack
I'm constant worrying about having a
unexpected young heart attack and or
choking by myself eating chips cancer
Cody calm sweet Jesus Jesus would love
this movie no one in the movie has sex
before marriage I think that's it
I saw if this was a boring video some of
these are gonna be boring because I
experienced real human emotions even
though I really really earned a say try
not to I don't know burn his body
oh say look great the best part was that
in front of memory and I wasn't the
drunken human being I've ever seen he
was doing the sway stand and then he
just kept leaning into the row in front
of him where these two browsers that I
am friend just having terrible drunk
conversation and just touching their
faces but he knew the lyrics to every
song and he would lean to the stranger
next to him and do this junk move when
you want to talk to stranger but you're
so drunk you don't know what's happening
he was like
I'm a slave for you he was great if he
wasn't a threat of falling I was like
you're excellent I wish you had just
like two or three less drinks in your
persons I don't really enjoy your
personality touching girls faces creep